all right so before I get into what is
going to really happen in this video I
would like to apologize about the fact
that this video is just 8 and a half
minutes long and was supposed to be
quite a bit longer there was still 14
minutes of video that I wanted to add
but sadly that was just ruined by my um
by my audio SRT like seriously I was
doing a stream at the moment and
suddenly the stream was gone no idea
what it was I think it took me like 20
minutes to get it back up to realize
that my audio call it crashed somehow
and for some stupid reason that also
resulted in a just collecting video from
fraps which meant that 40 minutes of
video recording we completely lost gone
just somewhere in the cyberspace and
yeah I can't really do stats so that's
why this video is quite short and why
I'm actually going to miss a tiny bit of
the entire making of this part you can
understand that I've tried to work
around this but there's no way to
retrieve that video file it is forever
lost and I can't get it this does mean
that since this is episode 98 I might
actually make it on my entire scheme to
like to the episode 100 stream that
would be absolutely amazing I would
really love to do it just like just for
fun seriously but yeah that's about
that's enough about that this was not so
much detail work as the other thing that
was just a tiny bit sleepy work but damn
it now I'm too late already [ __ ] I
should have I should have timed that
better yeah you know that I don't I
don't really like prepare for these
commentaries it just try to make [ __ ]
yeah let's just say [ __ ] anyway I'm
trying to just make stuff up all right
yeah that pier was just a simple thing I
wanted to end the path with something if
there's anything anything that annoys me
is when you gets useless path works
people always like to get their path
works around since it looks nice it's
really helpful to show of your area but
you don't just have port works going
nowhere and at the moment of having that
facade over there and just having the
path and right there it just ended with
nothing and I at least wanted to add
something simple at the end of it and
figured a peewee
be nice to actually give that end of a
path a tiny bit over use tiny of a
relaxing area also of the river over
there a tiny bit but also make that
River area look a tiny bit nicer and
less boring than just uh foliage
everywhere so that's why I did that and
then I went ahead and actually added
some more water lilies because you can
really see them before now there are
quite many water lilies in the water but
actually feel quite confident actually
did what I should have done in the first
place actually look up what they look
like in real life but not just that but
also how they actually form in real life
since it is quite a special thing and I
did once get that in a realistic way and
basically what happens is you either
have a non-moving body of water and if
you have a non-moving body of water and
there's the water lilies in them prepare
to spend them everywhere they're gonna
be completely everywhere the seeds of
whatever they spread are gonna be spread
all over that little non moving thing
plus you're gonna have green stuff all
over that thing that you can't beliee to
that and voila co second three so
usually I would just go with water
lilies everywhere everywhere but since I
do want to have a tiny bit of a stream
in this river by well human-made means
as since it is also a bit of a
human-made River just for this entire
project I would like to have a bit of a
huge a sewage system at the end of it so
also a tiny bit of a flow into the
direction of the log flume which meant
that the lily pads had to also
accumulate in like next two walls that
were also facing the log flume so that's
why they're only facing I am not
entirely sure what it is exactly but I
think that in a park the point entrance
comes from the south not really sure
nuts but in any case they would like
move towards the south and in case they
would move towards the park entrance
that's how all that works and this
bridge that I'm currently working on
damn I just keep lagging behind that
actually was it quite a bit of
interesting work in this time lapse I
should have sucked up before and didn't
really realize that this bridge over
here was to break up the boring look of
this place at the moment there was
really nothing over here but just
straight walls with just making the
canal and I didn't really want to have
that bridges are a pretty big part of
our canals look and really just want to
get a simple bridge over here a
different variation of what I already
had and even though this isn't entirely
how they look in real life you do have
many of those slightly curving wooden
bridges over smaller canals in smaller
towns in the Netherlands so I wanted to
get some similar thing in and while I
was at it also just wanted to get those
small stone platforms next to it it's
always nice to just add some small lamps
to that and also the flowers you guys
know that I life I just love flowers
I have so that was a good that was a
good opportunity to get those in as well
so that just works all around I would
say and then these little pillars are
the most realistic thing ever I the
problem is that in real life the size of
canals are far from the nicest thing to
look at the green that covered with
dirts and they're just not a beautiful
thing but this is a theme park and
sometimes I would say just choose the
good looks of the park just go for the
aesthetics rather than the realism
sometimes and I wanted to get some more
to that entire canal than just nothing
at the moment plus there is the problem
that's I know this might come as a
surprise to some people but a very big
change in what the Dutch cities look
like specifically the canals and the
paths and the size of bicycles bicycles
are almost a part of the scenery in
Amsterdam that absolutely everywhere
especially inside the [ __ ] canals
they're like they're just filled with
those things and yeah I can't get those
in I as far as I know there aren't
really any bicycle Custom Series sets in
Veliko second three and I sure as hell
I'm not able to model a bicycle and
Sketch up so that's also not really
gonna work and even if there was it's
not going to be quite the war of
bicycles that you would find in the
Netherlands and it's hard to really make
that work in a theme park you would have
to lock them all to certain places or
just make them bicycles that look like
real bicycles but in fact are just
grounded or something but ya know
although that was a fun idea I couldn't
really do anything with it so that's why
the sides of the canals are pretty
boring and empty at the moment
not much to do about that realistically
it's not many things that I can place
over there there's already planters and
little path elements so I basically felt
like the canal walls with the only thing
I could really work on I'm talking about
this rather than the foliage over here
at the back since the foliage isn't
really too much of an interesting point
really this is just the simple old
foliage trying to fill this in a tiny
bit add some simple flowers since it is
the side of the reign of the what the
railroad track and just wanted to
beautify that a tiny bit but as always
watch out with your flowers I see so
many people spam flowers absolutely
everywhere just think of the poor people
that need to maintain them please you
don't you see that everywhere in a theme
park so run it's fine as long as it's
next to the paths and still an
acceptable level but I wouldn't want to
go too far with all that all that stuff
I think that this at the moment was a
failed mission actually was this a
completely filled mission I think it was
a completely failed mission trying to
get some cornices that maybe could the I
couldn't make these canal walls look a
tiny bit less boring but it quickly just
gave up enough to finish the last tiny
bits of foliage over here next to the
station and that's going to be the very
last thing in this video as you might
notice um running out of time already
since it's such a short video over here
so yah ah it's going to be that tiny bit
of flowers over there I did feel pretty
safe adding flowers over here it is
quite it's pretty much the next to the
path and next to the station and all
that did want to make it look a tiny bit
nicer with some simple foliage I wanted
to keep it low over here since I wanted
the people to still be able to see this
station from the path and get that nice
view going but I did want to get some
simple foliage to make sure that I
wasn't completely empty and had that
empty grassy little place there so all
this low ground shrubbery is a sort of a
place filler I suppose that sort of
thing in any case that's going to be it
for this episode so thank you guys for
watching and I'll see you guys in the
next episode see you space cowboys